c'est une manière aussi pour nom de deux
pandas les appels à projets qui
nécessitent des moyens qui nécessite
aussi des chercheurs et quand on est
nombreux on est plus forts répondent à
des appels à projets coûteux et qui
demande du temps de travail pour monter
un projet donc c'est assez important
et puis ce sont les recherches qui sont
fondamentales pour nous pour nos
territoires me voyais aussi parce que
quand on fait de la recherche ne fait
pas que pour nos territoires
mais c'est une manière aussi de de
montrer que les nous sommes travaillent
ensemble pour le territoire le
développement de nos territoires pour
nos étudiants pour valoriser nos
territoires et nous avons aussi de la
recherche spécifique chez nous que seul
peut être que les caribéens sont
capables de remonter au plus haut niveau